panique à bord dans un communiqué commun
les entreprises du voyage et le syndicat
des entreprises de tour opérating ont
alerté le gouvernement de leur situation
nos organisations sont confrontés à des
demandes massives de remboursement en
numéraire justifiée ou non
dans ce contexte de fortes tensions sur
la trésorerie des entreprises
de tels remboursements mettre en péril
les entreprises ces deux organisations
qui représentent la quasi totalité des
agences de voyages et des tours
opérateurs ont informé qu'une baisse de
25% de l'activité avait été enregistré
au mois de février avec une décroissance
accru la dernière semaine de 60%
sans compter les demandes massives de
remboursement de la part de leurs
clients
la loi exigeant un remboursement en
numéraire nous vous demandons de toute
urgence de prendre les mesures décret ou
autre permettant de proposer comme
alternative un bon d'achat ou un avoir
valable un an l'industrie du tourisme
emploient 35 mille salariés directement
menacés de pertes d'emplois et plus de
3000 entreprises menacées de disparaître
de ce fait le gouvernement a déjà
reconnu le secteur comme étant
prioritaire dans cet état d'urgence
économique
[Musique]